c'est ça un disque isabelle novices
ouais les exégètes se sont mis au
travail alors on dit à nos vices n
obéissent et eux comme c'est écrit sur
la pochette
il ya aussi novice n os bsnes uno vice
en anglais tu penses quoi de ce genre de
tu comprends tout ce que tout ce que
bâillon effet sur toi dans dans
libération c'est une bonne question est
est-ce que tu comprends moi je ne
cherche pas à comprendre qu'on
définition des pleines pages sur toi
mais c'est toujours un peu compliqué il
raconte une aventure et il délire et
c'est une façon de parler de quelque
chose tu peux en parler avec le le nez
dessus
en décortiquant musicalement dit dans
tel musicien c'est pas mal ou le hic
c'est super ça c'est un aspect mais le
rang de légende heures je trouve ça sert
en s'allégeant des personnes ya toi yam
ans et liam y aura des gainsbourg et du
tronc vous êtes ses légendes ses biens
bah oui je suis surtout content que
fabriquer des personnes qui comprennent
la limite tout ce que je dis portes il
ya quand même deux tendances dans ce que
tu fais yalla yalla ligne dure
ces play blessures c'est technopole un
peu comme ça c'est ce que tu appelles la
cacophonie rigoureuse où les erreurs de
libérer ça c'est le bal chou
un peu artiste me dis qu un peu hard et
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui quand on
écoute play blessures
c'est beaucoup plus classique beaucoup
plus facile que quand on a écouté la
première fois et puis un peu le côté top
53 pizza et a passé le rio grande et qui
était comme ça à bourg et de calembours
1 et qui a été meilleur disque de rock
de l'année quand même je mets entre
c'est entre ces deux lignes comme ça
entre la ligne dure et la ligne pizza
disons tout sens où là bas depuis depuis
tu connaissais le disque avant pizza il
y avait roulette russe ouais et c'était
s'était pas vraiment
une forme de tore royaux à part quand
même c'est un peu ténébreux mais je
crois que ça m'a aidé à prendre du recul
sur moi enfin tu vois je tous ces mecs
qui gamberge trop comme ça que j'en fais
partie je me pose trop de questions et
puis finalement on sait bien aussi tu
vas mais ça me permet de bons de sourire
temps en temps c'est cher indices comme
ça à produire normalement ça doit pas
être cher je trouve que le dernier a
coûté trop cher la ville et combien
lannoy lys je sais pas peut-être 80 75
bruit ouais ouais y'a un truc comme ça
mais si je trouve je trouve ça
scandaleux donc fort il faut rendre
combien pour rembourser ne sais pas
peut-être 80100 minarets comme ça oui
c'est envisageable
ah oui bah je le vends correctement des
algues ont donc se prend il scelle fais
pas chier de compte et était comptable
compter des petits noirs j'ai failli
être considérés comment alors bastion
cantal
c'était un mec était sur des rails
parfait pour lui tu vas g
j'ai fait un stage chez péchiney une
fois encore
mais ça les airs il fallait faire un
dossier dont pour passer l'examen
ce rendu compte à quel point c'était pas
fait pour moi non et j'ai eu un refus du
chiffre total est et je n'aurais
peut-être pas dû avoir un refus
systématique du 6 août a peut-être que
richard lui voulait pas vendre le métier
de ton père boulanger
non j'ai taquiner un peu quand j'ai des
petits parce que j'étais un peu je
livrais d
des gâteaux pour les mariages d immense
gâteau guide est trois fois plus grand
que moi je venais pour voir les puits
par ces parures rester dans la farine
non le pétrin du cp dans les sorties
ouais et quoiqu'il en alsace mes parents
j'ai pas mal de difficultés à hydra
parise avait une petite pièce puis bon
je suis parti chez la grand-mère de
services quoi
c'était sympa
un petit village bon c'est pas facile
d'être de nulle part d'être le babyphone
damas à ces sacrés des trois familiaux
un peu de vent mais elle s blues goethe
à pikine je t'en prie merci
le prix ça fait pas mal de galères quand
même c'est vrai que tu as été producteur
de dick rivers
oui j'ai fait ça pendant trois ans ce
qui allait abandonner toute nouvelle sur
le devant de la scène
le climat s'y prêtait pas à tuer le seul
le seul darche qui fait des trucs faille
en avait quelques-uns y avait du tronc
non c'est beaucoup
c'était une période
très variété du il va pas forcément dans
le bon sens
c'est quoi le moment le plus dur à cette
époque le tri que tu voudrais plus
jamais revivre je vive avec une femme
c'était pas possible qu'est ce qu'elle
pensait qu'au fric et
moi je moi je pouvais gagner de l'argent
à travers une passion et je pouvais pas
me dire maintenant il faut que je gagne
de l'argent et la passion du rapt aurait
tué et j'avais ça en tête je ne pouvais
pas exister autrement alors si je sais
pas si c'est très égoïste
à quoi servent les artistes voici way
j'étais comme ça tu vois je
j'essaie de faire plein de jobs et rien
ne va rien de décoller au moyen de
réussite sûrs alors je trafic est un peu
à gauche à droite tu faisais comme une
musique à elle je faisais en faisait des
cover à l'époque de
d'autres artistes complices et les plus
grands succès de johnny hallyday par
exemple mais avec sa photo je vais
chanter par billy cheminots tu vas et
c'était toi qui es seat
mais moi je faisais les voix rauque euh
ouais de charge de leur écharpe jaune
parfois cet ennui quand on dit qu'elle
est géniale idée de la new wave c'est un
peu c'est un peu théorique pour pour moi
mais ça c'est pousser peut-être pas
complètement non mais c'est pas
totalement faux certainement mais ce que
mauriac
il a été
il a commencé par du rock quand même il
n'a pas baigné forcément dans la musique
classique
à ce moment là il ya des moments où tu
te dis j'y arriverai jamais ah ouais je
vais je ne veux rien à [ __ ] de me
réveiller le matin stade là puis un jour
ça allait tellement mal que je me suis
dit c'est là que tu découvres que
finalement tu peux pas descendre plus
bas et tu veux commenter quoi tu parle
plus ici voilà un problème c'est le
classique mais c'est vrai c'est pas des
conneries
maintenant tu tape un peu le look
famille bien le dire
ghost apple tu viens atterrés nous
parler de ton petit arthur qui vais
bientôt aussi célèbre que le petit lu
web et je veux pas faire oublier là
dessus bon dit comme ça c'est pas gênant
pour les fans 9 -10 troy
je crois pas parce que je j'ai des cuves
vraiment cette période là c'est pas
comme si je racontais des histoires de
science fiction tu vois et je souhaite à
personne de vivre ça dans cet état
je crois qu'il faut y arriver une autre
manière on peut y avait une autre
manière si ce n'est pas forcément facile
il ya un moment 82 tu disais
fa c'est je crois le moment où tu t'es
séparer de bergman pendant un moment et
u10 et j'étais à deux doigts de la mort
ça veut dire quoi ce nom il fallait que
gérard est pour cela que j aurais tu un
peu surpris en suisse
comme une star comme sartre il vous a
fait la clinique ensuite la clinique en
suisse tout parfaitement aux règlements
clairs et maintenant tu vois plus que du
café quaid l'oural et huawei là c'est
pareil c'est bien parce qu'il ya un
moment où tu sais que tu as fait ton des
problèmes
j'ai goûté à boeufs pas mal de trucs et
c'était bien là lorsque bon le médecin
il te dira un jour écoute tu t'arrêtes
tu crèves
et puis voilà tu pas faire comme
gainsbourg j'ai pas
oui il gère beaucoup moi j'en ai
beaucoup donc
j'imagine qu'ils marchent pas le disque
la novice tu te diras quoiqu'il ait pas
bon c'est les gens qui sont pas bons ce
qui est important c'est que je vois
d'accord avec cet album est d'accord non
je suis pas totalement blindés mais ce
qui me paraît plus important c'est
d'être d'abord d'accord avec cet album
et ensuite on verra
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'énergie dans toute question premier
morceau
[Applaudissements]
d
on y meurt après les souvenirs
bah je vais je vais souvent croisé à
cette époque là et
j'avais fait des chansons pour un micmac
de cette époque là c'était noël descend
ou grandes idoles de bayon ronnie bird
noël des champs
ces pièces
[Musique]
tous
l'anti we went on met tellement cheap
rappeurs n'ont toujours pas trouvé
alors ces six frappeurs qui joue qui
joue à la guitare c'est pas ça me couche
[Musique]
ces patriotes non c'est presque bah oui
ça me fait quand même senti qu'elle voit
c'est que tout ça me contournable plus
oui vous voyez pas ce qu'il y avait en
même temps à velouté pas mal ça compte
orchestration se souvient de cet album
où il y avait d'un côté des slovaques
couteau royal formidable c'est ça
exactement l'europe il dit
[Applaudissements]
ils sont
beaucoup d'albums de winson et jamie
sale dans d'un album à l'autre
il faisait des trucs totalement
différent si des fois avec des cordes
cette fois c'était produit généré un
produit par john boehner ouais c'est un
pote à lennon y avait toujours des
grands musiciens effet deux grandes
salles basses et curial parce qu'il est
pas n'est pas très connue en france mais
c'est parfois inspiré de deux de ses
passages coq à l'âne
il avait une voix incroyable et bien il
va il a fait tout un album aussi de
chansons de randy newman avec yellow man
2 art
bravo france au suivant ah ça c'est dur
mais c'est bien
[Musique]
on
l'eau
[Applaudissements]
camille
[Musique]
non bravo ça c'est très dur
produit par nick mason inc lors d'un
voyage qui était chez lui tu voyais les
paralytiques était chez lui dans sa cave
en train de trafiquer les sanctions sont
bizarres wayne superbe
je suis content que tu les trouves et
c'est moi qui fais à peine tu trouves
pas bravo aux suivants
déjà plus facile pour il s'agit comme ça
tu vas connaître
m
tel est son nom
en
attends c'est se soucier cc johnnie to
et johnny thunder et ses décors donnent
toulouse j'aimais beaucoup un album
acoustique de lui aussi ses limites du
loser c'est le fameux mythe
ouais ah ouais est ce que tous les
regards doivent être des losers bâches
ou non bon voilà on continue
[Musique]
suite
m
[Musique]
je pense tout juste tout brûle brûle
quand tu lis tout juste eu brûle parce
que sur cet album il y avait beaucoup de
musique avaient été faites par quelqu'un
d'autre et ça c'est lui qui a fait la
musique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
kylie pauvret c6 non mais c'est pas
facile mais tu es un bon centre mais pas
les rues facile c'est sixtine dans le
sport live et c'est pas beau week a fait
la musique et c'est bien que teddy
stooges parce que c'était son groupe
avant au suivant on peu près quatre ans
ça semble ça ressemble donne 6 comment
c'était quand tu faisais les bases
américaines j'étais comme ça quand même
j'aurais bien voulu enregistrer à cette
époque la star de salon mais on avait
toujours le trac elles ont joué toujours
très très vite le morceau je crois qu'on
a été bonne qu'avant beaucoup mais tu
sais ça l'ex espoir mines ne puis je
suis tombé sur un co un jour qui m'a dit
il faut que ce soit fort et rapide cette
année c'est vrai et pas vraiment pas
toujours me suivent en question
[Musique]
ça c'est le boss angeles
c'est baldhead non
ces gens ces gens donnent plus récent
volet web a trop forcé web départ fille
jalouse
j'aime beaucoup à horizon bien ça serait
bien de toi de mon livre est vrai
mélange de pas mal de musique entre des
riffs rares des rythmes blues
enfin c'est un des trucs qui va le plus
éclaté visuellement et musicalement on
les a eus dans un bain de minuit l'année
dernière pour les géniaux après six
nourrissons
bravo c'est darty boulevard lumumba qui
trouve pas ah oui et puis va bien ou
s'il va très bien le lien il tombé sur
une espèce de yoko ono du pauvre mais il
va bien faire gaffe à tout faire gaffe
elle tient bon la jeune fille
la chose bonsoir alors on a reçu ici à
quelques semaines ton complice tombe
parolier halte et parolier boris bergman
qui nous a appris une bien triste
nouvelle puisqu'il nous a dit que
maintenant après novice c'était fini
quoi je me suis rendu compte d'un truc
c'est que
plus on se fréquentait comme ça plus on
parlait et moi on écrivait des chansons
il avait l'air de dire aussi que tu
étais devenu quand même très court
humeur très quoi kooner c'est à dire que
tu étais avec chantal arthur les quatre
chats dans la maison oui mais vous avez
le même style de vie si j'avais la
preuve que sortir jusqu'à 9 heures du
matin tous les jours
en face de belles chansons je crois on
continuera le fait ouais à une époque où
vous allez traîner tout l'ena temps de
jaser parce que c'était complètement
tordue il y avait des vieux films
il y avait sept dégueulis dans les
chiottes il se passait quelque chose de
touchant tu vois là rien c'est clean
comment tu vas tu
comme un tube gagne donc avancer un peu
le bilan de nos vies cela sur la la
critique c'est parfait comme ça
ressemblait plus à appeler blessure qu'a
à rio grande et la critique a été
dithyrambique les ventes ça s'est passé
comment on va on va dépasser 110 ha ben
c'est bien qu'ils donnent
c'est complètement des rangers sont la
faillite en tentant savoir qu elle a
finalement même si c'était voulu
au fond de toi et avec le recul est ce
que la redescente après gaby après verte
et sap a été douloureux
maintenant je peux le dire moi ce que je
voyais ce fait que effectivement rien et
ses deux tubes qui à un moment donné ont
montré que je pouvais que cette musique
pouvait être rentable
e mais mon but c'était arrivé à faire
des albums qui ne se vendent et pas
seulement avoir une espèce de tubes et
ensuite tu fais un truc sur scène qui
est vraiment toi et tu passes ton temps
à expliquer sa vieille schizo j'ai fait
un tube mais vous savez je fais d'autres
trucs
bon ça st j'avais pas envie d'être à
côté de mes pompes et je crois que le
les gens s'intéressent aux albums et
près là on va faire l'interview première
fois j'essaie de me souvenir
premier boulot gdn j'étais un peu la
boulangerie ouais j'ai d un peu la
boulangerie je livrais des trucs que
j'ai livré des pièces montées pour
pour les communions pour les mariages
tout ça alors me donner une pièce
c'était avant la contre as well premier
fleurs ah oui elle s'appelait marie
jeunes avant oui
j'habitais dans une petit village qui
était tendance catholique elle habitait
dans un autre village d'un kilomètre et
chez elle c'était plutôt protestons il
ya des problèmes dans l'alsace on se
rencontre à mi-chemin dans l'alsace
ouais c'était l'enfer t'avais pas le
droit de jouer avec les petits les
villes en face comme tu dis dans la
chanson s'était coincée ouais si vous
arrivez les juifs les protestants les
cathos c'est du vrai de vrai j avais des
vieilles il y avait des idées des vieux
bouts de règlements de compte qui datait
de la guerre et intel qui avait dénoncé
l' intérêt et une telle qu'ils avaient
couché le reste l'équipe de l'hôtel
avant elle la france que la france est
la première fille avec qui tu as fait la
manche quand souvient ouest une brune
ouais c'était pas terrible c'était la
sortie d'un cinéma va s'y retrouver dans
dans un hangar entre entre une
moissonneuse batteuse et basques étaient
dans un hangar
machines agricoles tu vas et
j'étais très vite fait vers 17 c'était
déjà mieux et premier gars ont commencé
à prendre girl avait quitté fait l'amour
robert je suis encore vierge de ce côté
là oui oui oui je sais pas j'ai un jour
je me suis retrouvé dans un pieu avec un
mec comme ça il vendait comme un fouet
et même toucher à peine comme ça et moi
je voulais dormir boire j'étais étonné
par ce maître parce que je le faisais
bande et je trouvais ça fascinant tap a
essayé maintenant fait gars est
dangereux c'est gratuit l'époque ça me
paraissait dangereux aussi
donc la tessera puis première [ __ ]
ce sont 19 ans c'était une pierre charon
ce que je chantais dans un dvd put rue
pierre charron bayer d'un club qui
s'appelait le club cherche ans j'avais
été engagée je devais avoir 10 novembre
et je chantais cinq ou six chansons tous
les soirs avec une guitare sèche
mon porte harmonica j'ai chanté des
chansons de dylan barry mcgee est comme
ça yves destruction de destruction d'un
grand moment parce que c'est très bien
j'aime beaucoup et il y avait des filles
ou barre
et puis j'étais devenu copain avec m on
passait des nuits ensemble des fois puis
matin à me payer d'espagne où c'était
super
le protéger car allemand tu vas y aurait
pu mal tourner mais je ne voyais pas
comment des pages et quand on parle de
[ __ ] je suis un peu choqué par le mou
parce que j'ai vu des filles super
premier succès c'était beaucoup plus
tard c'était quoi le premier succès de
gaby jusqu'à dit rien c'était carrément
ouais on peut pas appeler ça
il y avait du bricolage partout entre le
moment où tu as décidé de devenir
artiste et le moment où tafer gaby il
s'est passé combien de temps dix ans dix
en dix ans tu y as qu a forcément mais
je rencontre toujours un conte qui me
disait écoute c'est bien ce que tu fais
je vais
c'est bizarre expliqué genre de truc
pourquoi tu tu insistes ou
c'est pas normal ce serait beau l'armée
ya peut-être certainement le fait que
j'ai essayé de bosser et essayer de
faire des trucs j'essayais de
mais je sentais tellement que il ya
décrit la vie pouvait pas être vraiment
fait avec et
une envie de gagner de l'argent comme ça
je préférais mourir
ouais c'est pas comme ça est devenue la
compta chez péchiney je te comprends
besoin j'ai vu tout de suite que
traitement si j'avais été comptable il
ya un truc ça marche pas c'est les
musiques de films tu as fais plein de
19,6 le fait cinq suspects et la
convaincre sa sortie pas pas une je sois
tu vas faire un cd un jour avec les
musiques de films de passion des jeux
mandatant j'aimerais j'aimerais bien
c'est sur un 24
quelque part je peux le remixer un jour
[Musique]
ce collector haythem un jour premier
million de nouveaux fronts oui quand je
devais avec bin ouais ouais
keystone ap je les ai pas vus en fait je
les ai pas vus beaucoup il ya tout de
suite eu des impôts j'étais en train de
divorcer
ouais c'était un ramdam
incroyable c'est ça qui est fantastique
quand ça marche parce que tu vois très
grosse île et les choses fantastiques et
tu veux a grossi aussi la connerie là et
la jalousie et tout ces trucs en plus
énormes aussi non bon premier procès
bondues bourse ouest peuvent laisser un
procès ça s'est arrangé quand même elle
demandait beaucoup elle a eu très peu a
été dur
elle demandait trop ou alors elle puise
ses attentions maman de tous
celle où est ta dernière volonté tu
devais mourir
ce serait quoi
hors jeu prendra un bain présentable
[Musique]